your favorite planet is Saturn how would
the Rings look from the surface weird
hmm from what surface from the surface
of Saturn so the surface is saying when
we see well when we see Saturn we see
those rings with your own Saturn
what do you seeing okay so first of all
I have to confess my favorite planet is
Earth
but after Earth this Saturday all right
and of course Saturn being a gas giant
has no surface so if I dropped you on
Saturn and you want to look at the Rings
you will descend down to the center of
the planet through the clouds with no
rings inside it what yeah well actually
what will happen is you'll reach a point
where the gases under so much pressure
it is the same density as your body oh
my god I've reached that point myself
hey go Bob up and down like a quark at
that location but there's probably a
very solid Center but it is probably
farther in than where you would look for
you so you need a way to sort of float
you get it like a balloon or something
and float on in those outer regions of
Saturn once there the Rings are awesome
how do I know because the seamy
spacecraft and Carolyn Porco booth has a
Twitter handle
I think it's Carolyn Porco actually I
called her Madame Madame Saturn and she
is she is the keeper and taker of these
images that the Cassini spacecraft has
produced of the Saturnian system and you
look at those images in super duper high
res it is as though the coolest thing is
these rings are stunning but edge-on
they disappear that's a finding are
compared to their width well yeah they
essentially disappear Galileo first saw
this in his telescope because he look at
his Saturn and he puts that and had
these big ears and he playfully called
him here's Saturn when edge-on it
depends on the orientation to Saturn in
its orbit and earth he has long enough
so that in the cycle of that
relationship
Saturn went edge-on into the Greens
disappear disappear
Saturn have beaten his children hmm if
you remember your mythology that's
exactly what like nods ready gee